[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí a América este es
el magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy la Organización de Estados
Americanos enviará una misión a Perú
luego de que el presidente Pedro
Castillo pidiera que se activara la
carta Interamericana Este es el
mecanismo de la oea para proteger la
democracia en las Américas luego de que
la fiscalía peruana interpusiera una
demanda constitucional en su contra tras
recabar más de 190 pruebas de sus
supuestos actos de corrupción
y visitamos Colombia donde se sembraron
más de 200.000 hectáreas de hoja de coca
en 2021 según la organización de
Naciones Unidas esto es un récord desde
que se tienen registros Es decir desde
2001 la nación cafetera es la mayor
productora de cocaína del mundo
y visitamos también Guatemala para
conocer un relleno sanitario que es la
base de la economía de miles de familias
pero con graves consecuencias no solo
para su salud sino también para su
seguridad debido a la presencia de las
maras por esto ong trabajan en
enseñarles otros oficios y nuestros
corresponsales nos traen su historia
y vamos a Perú o bueno a Washington
donde se reunió el consejo permanente de
la Organización de Estados Americanos y
decidió enviar una misión para observar
lo que sucede en el país andino luego de
que Pedro Castillo solicitará al propio
organismo activar la carta democrática
Interamericana esto después de que la
fiscal general Patricia Benavides
realizaron una exhaustiva investigación
sobre sus presuntos actos de corrupción
y presentará ante el congreso una
demanda constitucional en su contra con
el objetivo de que este inicio un
proceso con miras a destituirlo la oea
señaló que con su visita buscará crear
un proceso de diálogo con miras a
mantener el proceso democrático sin
embargo lo que la fiscalía está buscando
es iniciar un proceso judicial por los
presuntos actos criminales y no se trata
como tal de un debate político Castillo
asegura que se trata de una nueva
modalidad de golpe de estado mientras
que la fiscalía señala que el mandatario
Está tratando de obstruir a la justicia
la pugna los poderes se traduce en
rechazo de la ciudadanía según el más
reciente sondeo del instituto de
estudios peruano el congreso tiene un
84% de desaprobación y Castillo un 65
Mientras tanto surge la pregunta de si
la oea podría o no activar la carta
Interamericana Y qué podría significar
esto se descarta que se trata de una
intervención militar como se especuló en
el caso de Venezuela por ejemplo ya que
la misma carta dice que se basa en el
principio de no intervención en el
siguiente informe que preparamos para
ustedes les explicamos Qué es la carta
democrática Interamericana
en 2001 durante la Cumbre de las
Américas de Quebec los países que
integran la Organización de Estados
Americanos aprobaron la carta
democrática de Interamericana un
documento que contiene 28 cláusulas para
garantizar la institucionalidad en los
países que reconocen la jurisdicción de
la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos es decir en 20 naciones de las
35 que conforman la oea la carta
establece lo que estas naciones
consideran como ruptura democrática
violaciones a los derechos humanos y de
las libertades así como la falta de
independencia de los poderes del estado
el presidente peruano Pedro Castillo
invocó el artículo 17 del documento para
pedir la reunión extraordinaria del
Consejo permanente la cláusula Establece
que un país podría solicitar asistencia
de la oea para la preservación de la
institucionalidad democrática consolidar
la democracia representativa si bien la
carta Interamericana denuncia que se
rige por el principio de no intervención
Establece que en caso necesario podrá
optar decisiones dirigidas a preservar
el estado de derecho entre ellas lo que
sucedió el envío de una misión de
verificación de la situación sin embargo
en conversación con Franz 24 Salvador
herencia Carrasco ex asesor del tribunal
constitucional del Perú descartó que
haya una ruptura del orden
constitucional en el país andino la
carta democrática Interamericana tiene
una serie de situaciones para ayudar a
mantener y preservar el
institucionalidad democrática lo que ha
hecho el gobierno peruano en estos en
estos días ha sido solicitar una
audiencia por parte del Consejo
permanente frente a lo que se considera
son ciertas actuaciones por parte del
Congreso y otras autoridades que podría
menoscabar la institucionalidad
democrática de acuerdo a los artículos
17 y 18 la carta
previamente la Comisión Interamericana
de Derechos Humanos ya había señalado
tras una visita de trabajo que observaba
riesgos para la democracia las reuniones
de los consejos permanentes de la oea
podrían ordenar visitas podrían ordenar
informes pero a su vez lo más importante
es una labor de mediación y hay que
tener en cuenta que en la historia del
Perú la oea jugó un papel muy importante
la transición democrática entre el
régimen de fujimori y el gobierno de
transición de Valentín Paniagua la
defensa de Pedro Castillo argumenta que
la denuncia constitucional presentada
por la fiscalía en su contra ante el
congreso es ilegal pues la Carta Magna
sólo contempla a remover el fuero en
caso de delitos de traición a la patria
Castillo sobrevivido a dos procesos de
vacancia por incapacidad moral en el
legislativo lo que para sus
simpatizantes corrobora que se trata de
una persecución política
denuncia inconstitucional e ilegal sin
fundamentos y que carece de toda
corroboración y pruebas objetivas la
fiscalía señala que el castillo organizó
una red criminal para obtener ganancias
a través de contratos con el estado en
el caso puente tarata 3 una obra
millonaria licitada en 2021 por la cual
según el ente de investigador el
mandatario y su entorno habrían acordado
recibir el 0,5% del valor total del
contrato
vamos ahora a México donde el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador propuso
reformar las leyes electorales con el
supuesto objetivo de hacer más económico
el proceso democrático la medida es
polémica pues estipula eliminar el
Instituto Nacional electoral que es la
máxima autoridad el mandatario afirmó
que no quiere que haya fraudes pero el
mismo entel le otorgó la victoria en
y seguimos en Colombia que rompió su
récord de cultivos de hoja de coca con
un crecimiento del 43% entre 2020 y 2021
la administración de Gustavo Petro ha
dicho que la guerra contra las drogas
fracasó sin embargo expertos consideran
que el balance no es por todo negativo y
que los resultados no pueden evaluarse
únicamente por área de cultivos sembrada
Juan Pablo lucumí nos cuenta más
el área sembrada con coca en Colombia
llegó a su nivel más alto en dos décadas
de monitoreo según la oficina de las
Naciones Unidas contra la droga y el
delito el área sembrada con coca la
materia prima de la cocaína se disparó
un 43% entre 2020 y 2021 hasta las
204.000 hectáreas
de producción es de 1400 toneladas de
clorhidrato de cocaína un 14% más que en
el año 2020
para la administración de Gustavo Petro
que ha calificado la lucha contra las
drogas como un fracaso ha propuesto
regular los narcóticos crear programas
de sustitución voluntaria y aumentar la
financiación social en las áreas de
producción continuamos haciendo lo mismo
que se ha venido haciendo en los últimos
10 o 20 años el resultado no va a
cambiar
Si queremos revertir
esas cifras tenemos que hacer algo
distinto algo nuevo nariño y putumayo
fronterizos con Ecuador son los
principales departamentos del país con
narco cultivos según la agencia de la
ONU mientras el catatumbo una región en
el departamento de norte de Santander
fronterizo con Venezuela sigue la lista
sin embargo Leonardo Correa director del
sistema de monitoreo de cultivos
ilícitos dijo en diálogo con France 24
que no todo es negativo en esta lucha la
evaluación de una política de drogas no
puede estar basada únicamente en la
cantidad de hectáreas de coca que hay
Colombia una vez más es el récord
mundial de incautaciones de cocaína más
de 600 toneladas de cocaína fueron
incautadas y yo creo que entonces lo que
tenemos es una situación de un balance
en el cual en zonas muy específicas del
país tenemos esta situación de
incremento pero al mismo tiempo tenemos
unos territorios que permanecen libres
de coca
sin embargo las cifras de la ONU
contradicen los informes publicados por
Estados Unidos en junio de este año
cuando anunció que la producción
potencial de cocaína cayó en 2021 a 972
toneladas métricas y la superficie de
cultivos de Coca llegó a las 234.000
hectáreas
y vamos a la capital de Guatemala que
esconde en su corazón un verdadero
ecosistema en torno a la basura un
relleno sanitario que es la base de la
economía de miles de familias
recicladoras que se asentaron alrededor
los métodos de recolección son altamente
nocivos la filtración de las maras e
incluso las agresiones sexuales hacen
parte de su cotidianidad sin embargo
varias madres de esa comunidad le están
apostando a otro camino participando en
talleres de inclusión social ofrecidos
por ong nuestros corresponsales Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo y Aurora bayud nos
cuentan la historia
en la ciudad de Guatemala existe un
lugar que la municipalidad prefiere
mantener en la sombra se le conoce como
el basurero de la zona 3 de esta montaña
de basura se sustentan unas 40.000
personas ahí entre las 3000 toneladas de
desechos que expulsa la ciudad a diario
los recicladores sacan los materiales
que se pueden vender
flory aprendió el oficio a los 10 años
entonces los tengo que separar este es
Claro que vale menos este es cuadrado
que vale Quetzal cada uno lo suyo es el
plástico otros con menos suerte trabajan
con el vidrio exponiendo sus ojos y su
cara o con la chatarra traicionera para
los dedos
es duro pero también nosotros tenemos
necesidad Yo tengo cuatro hijos tengo
que mantenerlos mi esposo se murió hace
tres años yo no puedo dejar de darle de
comer a mis hijos me gustaría hacer una
costurera una que diseña ropa eso me
gustaría hacer
y lo está logrando esas manos que
trabajaron tantos años en manipular
desechos aprendieron a coser gracias a
la organización creamos
para hacer frente a la falta de
oportunidades para los habitantes de la
zona esa ong ofrece a las madres del
basurero clases de costura de serigrafía
o incluso de diseño gráfico tenemos por
acá el resultado final que son estas
bolsas Cindy también trabajaba de
recicladora pero cerró ese capítulo de
su vida para ahora guiar otras futuras
costureras todo con tal de no volver al
basurero donde cada año los derrumbeste
desechos o los incendios por el gas
metano provocan accidentes mortales
llega también mucha basura que sale del
hospital puede que uno se con
alguna aguja o que pueda que toque
cosas con desechos descompuestos o
papeles de baño en el basurero de la
pocas son las alternativas para soñar
fuera del vertedero
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí América por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Luis Fernando Montes
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web France 24.com y
Para más información de nuestro
continente Sigan viendo France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]